thank you for joining us America we're
so glad you are here Dee is with us in
Kansas City Heidi how are you I'm doing
well how are you better than I deserve
what's up in your world well I have a
question you know I'm familiar with what
you normally recommend for investments
and I've also heard you say the stock
market's not great for money that you
need in less than five years I'm 63 my
husband 67 we have about a half million
in retirement money and I'm wanting to
know if you have a blueprint for how to
invest that money to last a long time
and withdraw the money I've been tapping
the retirement income the last two
months you will not be withdrawing all
the money within five years you'll just
be drawing an income off of it and so I
would invest that in good growth stock
mutual funds like we always do if you
want to move toward you know we usually
say growth and income aggressive growth
international and a growth fund if you
want to make that a little bit more
conservative you can pull the aggressive
growth fund out and do a do a balanced
fund instead of that and that will make
that portfolio a little more a little
more stable a little less wild so to
speak but still the point is you're
invested in good mutual funds in and off
the half-million dollars invested you're
going to live off of the income it
creates or you're going to tear into the
principal and you're going to start
cutting up the goose it's laying the
golden eggs so you want to do something
where you can do that and you know so
you need to plan on living on
can you pull less than forty thousand a
year off and still live okay
it's tight but I pulled off 1,400 in
November and 1700 this month okay well
that would that would only be $18,000 a
year average yeah we have 1500 a month
in pension income okay well if you set
yourself up $2,000 a month coming off of
this and it was invested like we're
talking about it would run almost
forever okay so you think man's keeping
all of the 500
virtually all of it in the four asset
classes you described is the safe thing
to do it's what I would do it's what I
do I'm 55 and you know so I'm just
brought right behind you here and you
know so it's is there is there ever
anything that's a hundred percent safe
no but when you bought your home it's
not you don't have a guarantee you just
feel good about the investment over the
long haul because homes have a good
track record over the long haul but but
you've got a you've got to research it
you've got to feel good about it I feel
fine about that and so it is what I have
personally done and it's what I've
recommended for 25 years and you know we
were doing a millionaire themed hour
yesterday how to be a millionaire and
two of the millionaires said they
started following that exact track
several years ago and it you know and
their mutual funds alone we're over a
million dollars but the calls we took
just yesterday so it's not like I'm just
you know some kind of wild crazy out
here on the fringes making up some kind
of risky thing there's a fairly
conservative approach to investing and
so you know well diversified long track
record mutual funds and you know this is
not like we're playing single stocks I'm
not telling you to pick a stock I'm not
even telling you which mutual fund to
pick but those asset classes as you
called them yes that's the four I use
and if you want to make it more
conservative change the aggressive
growth out for the balanced and you'll
be just fine I think and again I think
so obviously because I'm doing it for me
so it's not any different really thanks
for the call you guys would be so rich
so fast and be able to do so much not
only for yourselves and for your family
but for others